[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
have six of the most careful gentlemen
that you could ever wish for in your
lives yep
there's six of them hey when careful
boys merge boys
when careful boys merch boys do you guys
have merch now do you guys have jacob we
have paul vaulting is not a crime it's
not a sport okay this is the freight the
word careful boys would be great it's a
great like it sells itself what about a
little cb logo well cb yeah you know
i don't know man that's the acronym of a
gang that i grew up in cbz what's the
stand for cool boys or chinatown boys
and i think they found these boys
cool boys yeah cool boys i think the
careful boys will [ __ ] up the cool no
don't say that they're my friends i
don't want to fight with that be careful
man we should definitely get that word
hey get that word in the streets for me
catholic boys
catholic boys i don't want to be a
catholic boy yeah joe do you want to be
in a catholic i think i'd rather be a
catholic boy than a cool boy there you
go you know not so steve you were
telling us
something happened something happened to
you
unleash yourself people like it when
you're serious yeah i guess so so uh
yeah so recently i was uh i was just you
know chilling at home
and uh get a phone call from my mother
hello and she's sitting and she's
unusually
sitting next to my father like
they're in the same room at the same
time and and she's like
stephen i have something i have to tell
you
and i was like okay well all right
and she's like i have cancer oh [ __ ] and
i was like oh [ __ ] like this is that's
[ __ ] crazy wow yeah
um and she was bummed that she couldn't
tell me in person because obviously i
live in vegas and stuff and she already
lives in like san diego anyway so it's
it's rough this is like i don't know
like 15 days ago or something tonight
dude yeah so then i was like boy whoa
this is pretty crazy and she was saying
that you know the it's still early like
the prognosis is solid like she's
looking at um you know breast cancer
which is you know pretty common right
the common ones yeah which is um i mean
nikki's aunts have had it but when it
happens to you it's just a whole
different jam how did she catch it was
there like a lump or like yeah there's a
lump and my old man made her go
so when she was sucking on her boob
he was like honey
that's not normal that's exactly what
happened something's up she goes you get
to go to the doctor yeah that's why i'm
constantly fondling boobs yeah that's
good me too i have to make sure that
there's no extra lump very inconsiderate
wait no you said it right yeah yeah
there it is that very
considerate yeah so yeah this is one of
those it's just one of those things you
know i think i think she's gonna be fine
you know i think it's gonna be i think
it'll be like i think honestly i think
she's um
she's been in a place for a long time
where she's been taking care of so many
other people i think it's time for her
to take care of herself a lot more so
it's like one of those wake-up call
things so uh
is she just going to get like
surgery to just cut out that area or
whatever that's the plan yeah so she
started doing radiation and then they're
gonna do um they're gonna land some of
it to analyze it and then they're gonna
do
like a surgical procedure to remove the
whole jam it's crazy because like people
live day-to-day like they're invincible
but mortality is so real like at any
given time like someone could just
bounce you know and it's so sad even
though you know it's gonna happen like
why like
i'm telling my brain like people die all
the [ __ ] time every single day it's
not special it happens yeah but why do i
gotta get so [ __ ] sad over it when i
know that it's gonna happen yeah that's
why i knew this would be the great room
to talk about her dan
hey steve don't worry people die every
[ __ ] day all the time i'm like that's
very true good point
does that make you feel better
don't you feel burdened
by how much the [ __ ] pain takes you
out
oh i'm i'm worried for my mother because
she's a she's a warrior person right and
she just doesn't want to worry us and so
so it's mostly about that
yeah just how is your family taking it
like your brothers or sisters yeah it's
it's just one of those things where ever
i think we all feel the same way where
you know life is a is a weird thing like
but you know our mother is the best of
us we all feel and so it's one of those
tough things where so you don't rub it
in their face like your mom's face
anymore at least about luna right i
don't know well i never had to rub in my
mom's face because she was always blue
yeah it was always clearly the best of
y'all yeah yeah my siblings so they can
all suck dicks and die in hell but i'm
kidding no they're we're all everybody's
you know we're all abandoned together
about it but but it's also very it looks
very good you know it's just one of
those things where i just you know i
hope that more people you know i know i
i don't always do it like where you you
just take time out of your life to
appreciate the ones you love and stuff
so yeah not a bad time to do that that's
pretty tough but your mom is in pretty
good spirits about it as well oh i think
so yeah even though she's a warrior
she's a tough chick man she's the
toughest broad i ever known she probably
worries more about everyone else right
she does that's all she cared about was
that she was like she was only crying on
the phone because she couldn't like hug
me herself and stuff no
yeah it's like all that kind of stuff
worry about how you feel tell me yeah
it's like one of those things but it's
like dude i'm worried i you know i'm not
worried about her yeah yeah yeah is she
is she old how is she she's old dude
she can't be down she's not she's like
60s that's still young not that old
actually yeah my mom's a [ __ ] dust
bag compared to yours well how would you
mom
she's like 50. she had me at 38 or 39.
so plus that by 30. let me [ __ ] mad
only one like
a calculator joe doesn't know how old
his mom is 76 that's why the calculator
is always over there
joe's always coming for this one
anywhere from 74 to 76 because then she
told me 70 80 yeah okay that's dude
that's geriatric though 74-76
but she's still like pretty sentient
like she doesn't have like memory loss
rapidly my step-dad has cancer he
doesn't act like it
really he has colon cancer are you
supposed to act like
like a [ __ ] sad ass dude okay but he
has a baseball cap with the propeller at
the top and yeah he's like hey man
with a rainbow lollipop
but you guys ever think because i think
for me i've been really recently
thinking about like my parents mortality
a little bit more yeah you have the
youngest parents here my parents are
probably around your guys's age
okay your parents you're a parent
um i was like wow i was like we're going
to throw it away
because you've got older sisters right
yeah so like my sisters are probably
closer to your guys's age yeah
like yeah around there and so my parents
are
probably your parents age as well so
like 70s like around there too or like
her late 60s early 70s but uh like my
dad had a stroke probably around
like two years ago and just seeing how
that happened and because he was just a
normal like guy and he was uh
he was very active
and then once he had the stroke it did
kind of change him a little bit as far
as like he couldn't walk that well
anymore and then he moved to taiwan he
got more chill yeah you got way more
chill but you see that change you think
about that because you see your parents
in the hospital bed and you really think
about like oh [ __ ] my time with my
parents and my family
is very limited is getting to that stage
and then you you have to be more at
least for me i've been more
aware of how i try to spend time with my
parents but it is [ __ ] really scary
to think about i heard stroke is pretty
common in like um asian males oh yeah
that's that's like
super common in filipinos yeah heart
heart problems stroke blood pressure
yeah blood pressure that's another one
yeah my dad my dad already like has told
me that he's convinced that he the way
he's gonna go is by heart attack because
of like
uh you know his dad and his grandpa
stuff all heart attacks
[Music]
same with my grandparents heart attacks
all of them
but my grandpa like you know died in the
sleep but it was still like heart
failure or whatever like that so
but he's just the way he says it or the
way that he told me it seems so
accepted
you know what i mean like there's this
kind of air of nonchalance as if like
the fate has been accepted so it's just
like cool move on now that you kind of
know damn does that give you any sort of
like in a weird way but like
does it kind of make you feel a little
more comfortable with it at least in
your mind honestly i'm so [ __ ]
selfish that it makes me think like oh
[ __ ] i think i'm gonna have a heart
attack then i guess if that's how it
works because you think it's yeah what i
mean
oh okay would you call yourself a
stressor like do you stress about like
menial things or like or or does it take
something big to stress you out i would
say uh it would take something big to
stress me out but it doesn't mean i
can't have moments of sensitivity to
things okay if that makes sense yeah but
is it is it sensitivity like stress or
is it like something else no i don't
think uh stress overly consumes me in a
way that like i know that like it's
impairing my health no not like that
but who knows when you're like a father
of like that age and like things are
just you know what i mean hey dude my
father-in-law's like that like every
little thing stresses him the [ __ ] out
like to a unreasonable level yeah and
then what's something small
that he would freak out over oh dude i
mean just like nikki growing up didn't
clean her room one time and it like made
his face red and he was like you're
grounded for a week and like he's all
[ __ ] breathing heavy and [ __ ]
yeah so it's just yeah he'll just get
like become a rage monster and stress
about nothing out of nowhere right my
dad's the same way um but my dad hasn't
my dad also has a heart condition too so
i guess
but it's not as bad as his like my my
old my old man-in-law had to get like a
little uh
little pacemaker like oh [ __ ] my uncle
has heart problems too he just had
surgery
damn so that's like a lot of maybe
there's like something there with like
males and heart problems and stress and
blood pressure and heart disease is like
angry most common that's the most common
heart disease
oh yeah and it usually isn't that that
like spectrum of like strokes and how
closely tethered it is to your stress
level is key today's video is brought to
you by bombass
bombas mission is simple to make the
most comfortable clothes ever comfy
and match every item sold with an equal
item donated so when you're buying bonus
you're also given to someone in need
which is super cool bon bons designed
their socks shirt and underwear to be
the clothes you can't wait to put on
every day everything they make is soft
seamless tackless and has a luxuriously
cozy feel they're made from super soft
materials like merino wool pima cotton
and even cashmere wow which makes them
the perfect cozy layers there's a pair
of bomba socks for everything that you
do they come in tons of options like
comfy performance styles for every sport
and activity that keeps you moving
boneless t-shirts they're made with
thoughtful design features like
invisible seams soft fabrics and the
perfect weight so they just hang right
bulma's underwear has a barely there
feel with second skin support that might
make you forget they're even there in a
good way and did you know that socks
underwear and t-shirts are the three
most requested items at a homeless
shelter that's why bulma's donates one
for every item that you buy go to
bumbus.com off the record and get twenty
percent off your first purchase that's b
o m b a s dot com slash after record for
twenty percent off bumpus.com
off the record do you think it's
psychological more than dietary i could
tell you right now it's like because my
family has the same thing um all for my
grandparents
heart attacks and strokes oh my woman
too yeah men and women my dad and mom
both have uh heart issues and
um
when i was 17 i was already me and my
mom were having like a full-on argument
yelling at each other and she had a
heart attack in the middle of our
argument oh my gosh
so like ever since then why you always
got to top it
bro out of nowhere nonchalant but that's
like that's how i realized like it's
also your responsibility to
like yeah your parents got to eat right
whatever but you also have to not stress
them out how did that go down so in the
middle of arguing and then she was just
like clutching her chest it's exactly
what you would imagine like we were we
were fighting about it was my fault like
i was a shitty ass teenager and we were
just yelling and then all of a sudden
she just was like ah and just like
dropped like in the middle of us
shouting so what did you do call the
police i had i called the yeah i called
the police or the they sent the
ambulance and i was just holding her and
i was like damn
this is gonna be my fault i'll never be
able do you ever get like the the
thought like
another man arguments don't [ __ ]
matter like that's yeah from then on i
was like nothing is that [ __ ] big of
a deal like nothing especially this like
whatever this is ryan ryan is the dj
khaled of [ __ ] crazy stories
and he just pulls him out of random too
but then like you know that's that's
also something my parents also remind me
is in me too so they're like yeah don't
ever forget like at some point you might
hit an age where your cholesterol will
start going up and your blood pressure
it's gonna be a challenge to maintain i
still can't imagine that happening to me
because i've never had problems but
you know it's it's one of those things
where you have to be mindful of that too
you know like how how you live your life
it's not like one day the doctor tells
you hey you got to watch your blood
pressure you can't get rid of those
habits of being angry on the spot like
it takes years and years of disciplining
yourself how you live how you react to
things oh yeah so that's from that
happening at 17 i was like [ __ ]
you know i try to bob marley my whole
[ __ ] life it's just like hey it's
everything to be okay you've been
working on it since 17 yeah because 17 i
was [ __ ] hotheaded chill you are
though like i can tell you've been
through a lot
you know it makes it makes so much more
sense because usually people that are
like
i'm like man you haven't really been
through that much but if you go through
a lot of [ __ ]
like you're just like oh this guy's been
through a lot because they're not easily
stimulated well yeah it's very like rare
that something seems like it it should
cost that much yeah yeah
after you've seen your mom get a heart
attack in the middle of you yelling
about something that means nothing at
all like could have easily not even
fought about this thing my my dad hasn't
had anything yet but like
some of the signs of like him aging was
um like my dad's like moving some of his
stuff into our house so he'd sell his
house to move vegas
and he was like uh can you move this
downstairs for me because i can't pick
it up
and i want to go touch it and i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's crazy like this is
something that i felt like he's got
wheat like a 50 year old man
six-year-old man can easily move but
he's not 50 or 60 70 now and i'm like
wow this is great like this is i can
clearly see
he's not like like the dad in my mind of
yeah he's weathering apart and you at
the same time you're kind of like man i
lift i've been lifting a lot you're like
i'm pretty strong is it is it also that
change yeah
like my program is really good it's not
stronger is what it is
but that's a pushy you can't lift this
up no because he had a big tub of stuff
and he got the tub from the garage
but once he filled it up he was like he
couldn't move it anymore and i'm like
wow that's crazy or he or he could move
it he was like [ __ ] it hey bart yeah
[Laughter]
man thank you thank you for sharing that
man that's crazy you know i've been
meaning to talk to you guys about it i
just i i just never it was like we were
having such a fun time yesterday the day
before i you don't want to ruin the
movie yeah yeah but here we're at the
end of the shoot now so it's yeah yeah
how's your dad taking it he's you know
really well but um because i feel like
the the spouse takes it the hardest
because like that's their person yeah
yeah it's almost like you dying i called
him and i asked him i was like hey look
i know everyone's making a big deal
about ma right now but like i just want
to see how you're doing and [ __ ] and he
uh he got choked up about that because
like you know no
you know
guys we nobody as a guy yeah we very
seldom ask each other how we're doing
and [ __ ] and so uh yeah he was
definitely it's definitely one of those
things it's a good thing to ask right
like hey how how are you two like
everyone's gonna focus on the one person
we've been calling her non-stop sending
loved or non-stop but like hey how's
how's he doing and uh yeah he he doesn't
like just tell me exactly what up but
hearing him get choked up was enough and
then
you know him just changing the subject
into house nicki's parents is pretty
good and
that's kind of how he deals with yeah
that's it sounds like this guy just
[ __ ] deflects how's nikki's old house
nikki's father oh he's a
i'm like he's he's great daddy he's had
the pacemaker for five years he's been
fine i tell you that every time we're on
the phone
but you know he doesn't want to talk
about it yeah yeah yeah
he wants to ask someone a question we
all got to deflect though if if you're
if you can't you know because i i get it
too because he's talking to his son and
i'm his oldest son he doesn't mind like
she'll scare you yeah i think so i think
so yeah so i get i get the psychology of
it but i'm i'm also like hey it's okay
old man like uh life's too short like
man i can't wait to have kids i can
[ __ ] pour all my issues on to them
oh [ __ ] like
i can't wait you to get older so you can
rescue me
i just feel very fortunate because you
know some some people get the call and
it's very very bad news yeah yeah it's
already like too late
and it's like it's happening yeah yeah
i'm very i feel very very lucky i'm i'm
very grateful for anything uh it feels
like you know life gave me a little
wake-up call about you know the finality
of of like your closest ones and even
though i do i do a lot of jokes about
how i don't want to talk to my mom on
the phone and stuff i talk to her like
more than anybody
um so it's just it's just
it's just one of those things where uh
like
like the idea of losing like your best
friend in a way like is like yeah just
you gotta you gotta be more thankful
when jill's dad passed it was sudden
like that
this is when me and gio were living in
our downtown place in la
and it was like 5 a.m in the morning she
gets a phone call she never really wakes
up i don't know for some reason her cell
phone was on so rang she picked up the
older sister was like uh dad had a heart
attack and you just hear her crying over
the phone
and then i was like what the [ __ ]
and then um she's like i gotta go and
then i'm gonna go with you she goes no i
gotta go okay this is like your dad i
don't wanna like
i think she just needs space or like you
need to sort some [ __ ] out or whatever
and then it was just crazy that like
it was just in an instance where it was
the week before we're just having dinner
and you just like i was saying like how
like you just think everyone's just
gonna live forever right that's how you
live day to day and it was just bam he
was just just gone like just doing his
one of his normal
um gigs because he's a carpenter he's
just building a house and then
in a car ride uh he had a heart attack
and then next thing you know he's
already an ambulance [ __ ] he's crazy
yeah and it's not like he's like it's
not like he's super old or anything it's
just like you're just like wow he's
[ __ ] crazy man i think i saw him like
just like a couple weeks before that
because he was helping me build
something
and then and then that just and then
afterwards i was at the funeral and i'm
like
you were just like alive this is how
this is how quick it happens
did he have any history of heart stuff
or this was just out of nowhere not that
i know of i mean they're not like
the healthiest of people you know i feel
like that generation people just don't
really focus on the health or they don't
go on the daily walks or whatever you
know
so it's not i don't think they were the
healthiest before old dude he worked
like like physical jobs you know so it's
there weren't any signs
or anything like that and then it was
just
bam also men are really like terrible at
letting people in on signs oh yeah
they'll just bury that [ __ ] and just
never get the help they were supposed to
get but do you think it's also like um
um they're unaware or like no dude they
say they say like guys uh one of the
number one ways for guys to die
is when they get when they choke on
something
and because they don't want to burden
other people
one of the leading versus chicks would
be like oh [ __ ] like someone help me but
i think dudes are like i [ __ ] got i
got it and then they just you sure can i
help them like get off me [ __ ] you
know the s word all right and then they
just die off the side sorry all right
[ __ ] me then like a year ago a year so
dumb people will die to not look gay
you can't get behind me dude
like a year ago i was i was helping
nikki clear out some patio furniture and
it was like no big deal and she had
turned like a bunch of patio furniture
upside down and and all of it was the
same weight so i was just picking them
up take it outside taking the girl well
in one of them she stacked a bunch of
these wet pillows because it had just
rained and so it's just it's [ __ ] wet
pillows in them but i didn't even look
at it i was just picking them all up
like same same same and then i go to
pick up one and all of a sudden my back
just goes it was like it was like my
back just like lethal weapon rock and
roll guitars things like
that
and i was like oh my [ __ ] god right
and uh yeah i dropped it and then like
just
like for some reason i couldn't tell her
about it for like two months
really but like yeah it's just bad i
just don't want to bleed on her what
kind of is that what it was like you
felt like
you would murder her
well i just didn't want to be a [ __ ]
you know i mean how did you hide that
how did you hide those symptoms around
it
did you have anything like after like
any injuries well i can't [ __ ]
excuses as to why i couldn't do regular
things like
i don't feel like it now i got like a
little headache tonight whatever i'll
say i have a little headache but i won't
just admit i have a [ __ ] actual
backpack you're like
yeah i can't move she's like you wanna
come watch tv and i'm like ah i can't i
got a little headache it's like uh the
light will probably focus like you're on
the computer i'm like that doesn't yeah
it doesn't have to make sense okay
like you know and i mean
does that make sense i'm in here with
the officer a heat pad that i ordered
from amazon i opened it privately
and like he hated it up in the microwave
and i put it on my back and i'm just
like trying to do all kinds of different
[ __ ] yeah stupid thing too much wasting
food items and [ __ ] you got that [ __ ]
inversion table
upside down with the gravity boots
it's to make you better at [ __ ] yeah
yeah this helps them with crypto [ __ ]
business
crypto okay
i get big stinking rewards from this
thing
it's a miner
it's a miner
we're going to be rich you bobcat shut
up leave you alone
anyway tell people that you love you
love them it's always always a good
thing
you